so you said you had strong opinions
about uh
legalization in new york uh uh pot
legalization gets fast track on cuomo
lawmaker deal so why don't we talk about
that let me go to page six here
on what happened with our buddy cuomo so
cuomo has not had the most exciting last
few weeks
now it comes out that new york is ready
to legalize recreational marijuana the
state would impose special pot taxes and
prepare to license
dispensaries under an agreement reached
by governor cuomo and legislative
leader the deal that legislative leader
brokered with cromwell would legalize
cannabis use for adults 21 years or not
years old and up and includes a 13 sales
tax
nine percent of which would go to the
state and four percent to localities let
me give that to you one more time
the deal would allow cannabis used to be
legal for 21 and up
13 sales tax on it nine goes to the
state
four percent goes to localities the
governor's office estimates that a legal
cannabis program could pull in 350
million dollars a year
once fully implemented assembly major
leader crystal people stoke said with
new jersey legalizing marijuana earlier
this year we are literally surrounded
graphically by other states that are
doing
it we just need to stay ahead of times
because we're new yorkers
we can walk and chew gum at the same
time we can speed this up
tom what are your thoughts on this uh i
think you should take away the word
cannabis
and put in alcohol or a lottery and then
insert the word
the benefit will go to the schools this
is right out of the playbook of every
state in the nation
who understands when something's up and
i can tax it and i can take advantage of
it
and the wave of momentum is coming over
them they go with it and i think new
york's just going with it and
you know we're going to legalize alcohol
and we're going to get a tax on it and
the benefit will go to the school
do you think it's good or bad but the
question is do you think it's good about
because
let's face it i know a lot of people in
new york that would probably take
advantage
of this i'm sure a lot of people in new
york are going to go out there and say
okay great
350 million dollars is 350 million
and god knows new york needs tax money
because they lost a lot of people to
florida which means they need to find a
way to
generate that revenue back just a basic
question
is this a good strategy or is this a bad
strategy
i think it's good for new york well you
saw in chicago matt what did you see
yeah illinois january 2020 is when
illinois
made the sale of cannabis illegal
recreational
wise uh right before the pandemic go
figure
illinois illinois yeah just in time for
a chill year
exactly so 10 was a sales tax in
illinois generate half a billion dollars
in
in revenue for illinois literally from
my office pb
two blocks just north of my office is a
recreational
uh marijuana lounge i mean you walk in
it's beautiful like a cigar
oh like a cigar line you go in there and
it's just it's beautiful
it's it's well laid out it's really nice
uh interior design
i mean they decked it out really
apparently it's a chain what was the
address
people would like to know what's
interesting right right 220. what's
what's actually name of what's the name
of the place uh it's uh what is it it's
called consume
it's called consume go figure consume
they got in illinois they got in in
michigan they got a bunch of
dispensaries uh there's a network
and it's literally two blocks away from
our office
and you know for me as a parent it's not
only is it
a revenue generator from illinois but it
it challenged me as a parent
uh you know my you know my my kids you
know dad everybody smoking pot everybody
smoking pot
and then i i was i would discipline my
kids for this for for
for for marijuana use and the times i
disciplined them they didn't like it and
then you know my kids now older
you know my son's 25 my twins are 19.
they're like oh well poppy it's illegal
now all the times you put
your discipline does so yeah you know
from from a parent to standpoint it's
challenging because you have to you know
stick to your values and principles even
though
just because you could doesn't mean you
should uh type conversation with the
kids
but from a revenue generator for those
who are adult and those who know what to
do with it whether the recreational
medicinal
got a bunch of veterans that consume
this medicinally
that's what i'm thinking what about what
about utah what do you think going back
to new york to answer the question
directly i think it's
new york is surrounded by states that
have taken the legislative approach
let's tax it let's continue forced a
little bit yeah they're kind of being
forced into the economic sanity
and uh stabilization and you know
people are gonna drive to connecticut
people can drive in new jersey or get a
buzz and drive home
you know one thing on this i still feel
very strongly about
no i mean breathalyzers are here to
help monitor drunk drivers and to keep
the rest of us safe
and i think we still i don't think
anybody has talked about figuring out
how do you judge
a real device to see that someone's
impaired because i don't want people
driving impaired
even if it's legal and you know my kids
go to college and
they smoke if they do if they choose
i want to bring up good standards about
them about being intoxicated
you know but um wait what just happened
right there if you so if your kids
go to school and they drink and they
they they smoke weed and you want to
bring good standards i don't understand
that part now what i'm saying is i i
want to equip them with great judgment
skills so as adults if they choose to in
indulge you know i have my feelings
about what i hope they do and don't do
but
if they choose to you know i want them
to do so
legally ethically with care and
consideration for their fellow citizens
and i think on the marijuana side we
still don't have a good
breathalyzer for marijuana because
somebody's baked i think it's a good
idea they're not driving heavy
we really not have anything for that yet
is uh driving under the influence of
course you have your breathalyzers for
alcohol but do you have any
utilizers for lack of a better term
that's the point
so there's nothing right now to find out
if somebody's smoking weed and driving
my understanding there is not a
consistent
approved 50-state device the way the
breathalyzer and the blood test at the
hospital for alcohol question becomes do
they drive better or worse
that's the question what do they see do
they see new cars do you see like
unicorns do they see
lanes multi-dimensional lanes others
don't see i think we've i think we've
gone to acid pat
this is what we're talking about and
none of us are referencing anything from
any personal experience so
we have no clue yeah i mean there's a
lot of innocence at this table
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye